Bună, numele meu e Katy Beslado
sunt directorul de strategie IBM Quantum
și cercetare în aplicații. Sunt aici ca să demontez
cât mai multe mituri despre calculul cuantic
posibil în șaizeci de secunde.
Calculatoarele cuantice sunt absolut reale
și avem dispozitive în cloud-ul IBM acum pe care oricine le poate accesa.
Da, dar doar pentru anumite lucruri la care sunt cu adevărat bune
matematică super complicată, cum ar fi cea pe care rulează universul
dar dacă vrei să faci foi de calcul sau email, folosește-ți
PC-ul.
Da, teoretic, dar nu
prea curând. Nimeni nu face un calculator suficient de bun ca să facă asta
deocamdată. În viitorul previzibil suntem pe drumul cel bun
și când ajungem acolo o să schimbăm modul în care protejăm
informațiile.
Complet fals. Calculatoarele cuantice
sunt fundamental diferite
și folosesc legile naturii pentru a procesa informații.
AI-ul de astăzi rulează pe dispozitive clasice tradiționale
dar credem că vor colabora în viitor.
Nu e adevărat, avem un ecosistem enorm
de startup-uri, academii, laboratoare naționale și parteneri din industrie care
folosesc dispozitivele noastre în fiecare zi.
Nu. Calculul cuantic inspirat există
de multă vreme și rulează pe dispozitive clasice. Ele
nu vor livra niciodată promisiunea calculului cuantic.
Dacă vrei calculul cuantic, trebuie să o faci cu calculatoare cuantice reale
computers